In this section, we continue by taking a look at how we can use the face control rig with
the face pose library to create animations using a forward solve, and then we will go
over how we can adjust an existing animation with the face control rig using a backward
solve.
So, let's jump into Unreal Engine and begin exploring the face control rig.
When using the face control rig, make sure that the gizmo is set to translate and is
in local space and snapping is turned off.
Since the face board has over 200 controls, one way to quickly pose the face is to use
the face pose library.
To do this, in the animation panel, select poses.
The pose library is located in the metahumans common folder, so in order to add that in
here, right click over here and select add existing folder to view.
I have already added the metahumans folder in here.
Now, I will open up the metahumans folder, then open up the common folder, then open
up the second common folder, then open up the pose library folder, and select the face
folder.
Inside of here, we can select from a variety of expressions and visims.
If I open up the expressions folder, inside of here, we can choose a face pose we want
to add.
I will double click on this pose.
Right below, I will click on select controls.
Then with key checked on, I will select paste the pose.
That pose will be keyframed in sequencer.
We can move a few frames over and select another pose.
Double click on another pose, and since select controls is still enabled, we can select paste
the pose.
And this is how we can use the face pose library to quickly pose and create animations using
a forward solve.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
When using the face control rig, you may find it helpful to also go through all of the face
controls in order to learn what each control does.
For a detailed breakdown on each of the face controls, you can reference the facial description
standard portion of the metahuman documentation, and that is linked in the resources portion
of this course.
Now let's jump back into Unreal Engine and go over how we can use the metahuman control
rigs for a backward solve.
Now let's use a backward solve.
First we need to delete the face control rig.
Now I will add an animation track by going to the plus sign on the face component, and
then go to animation and select the mh face animation sequence.
This is 644 frames.
Next I will change the sequencer length by going down here, and I will enter 644.
I will now use the end bracket to change the length of the sequence, and now I will go
to the start of the sequence and play this.
Now there may be some areas of this animation that you may want to adjust.
In this case you can use a backward solve by baking the animation curves to the control
rig.
To do this I will go to the start of the sequence, I will right click on the face component,
and then select bake to control rig, and select the face control rig.
I will leave everything at default, and select create.
Depending on the length of the animation this may take a moment.
Once this process completes, we can see that this animation has been baked to the face
control rig.
Now we can either adjust the existing keys of this animation using the curve editor,
or we can add on top of this animation using an additive backward solve.
To add on top of this existing animation, let's go to the start of the sequence, and
then go to the plus sign on the control rig track, and select additive.
Now to create an offset, I will select the brow lateral control, then hold down shift
and select the other brow lateral control, and then select the brow down controls.
Now if I move these controls and set a key by pressing the letter S, this offset will
remain throughout the entire animation.
Another thing we can do is add animations to specific sections.
If I scrub through this animation, and decide that at this section, when the character is
smiling, I want to adjust the cheek raise controls only when the smile is occurring.
I can select the cheek raise controls over here, and I will scrub back to the section
right before the smile occurs.
Here I will create a neutral key by pressing the letter S.
Now I will go back to the section where the smile is occurring, and use the slider to
move the controls, and set a key.
I will now move a few frames over, and use the slider to decrease the cheek control values,
and set another key.
And this is how we can use an additive backward solve to either create an offset, or edit
specific areas of an animation by adding on top of it.
To export this as a new animation sequence, I will go all the way back to the top of a
And then I will right click on the face component, and select Bake Animation Sequence.
Now, before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
We have just taken a look at how we can edit an existing animation using a backward solve
with the face control rig.
For a backward solve, we first have to delete the default control rigs from Sequencer, and
then assign an animation to either the face or body component.
Then right click on the face or body component, and select Bake to control rig.
From there, you can either use the curve editor to make adjustments to the animation curves,
or use an additive layer to add on top of an existing animation.
To create a new animation sequence with all of the changes that you've made, right click
on the face or body component, and select Bake to animation sequence.
Now that we have seen what we can achieve with the metahuman control rigs, let's move
on to different ways we can apply animations to our metahuman characters.